manger sain et local dans les
restaurants universitaires c'est le pari
lancé par les crous de france dans
l'ensemble de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
dix-huit mille repas par jour sont
servis à 3000 étudiants et rien que sur
ce site de guyancourt jusqu'à 500 repas
sont vendus quotidiennement dans une
telle cadence le crous de versailles
tente de s'engager dans une démarche
nutritionnelle scène c'est une même
politique qui est surtout basé sur la
qualité du produit et la valorisation du
fait maison
les repas sont élaborés par des chefs de
cuisine dans des cuisines pour chaque
site
on n'a pas de cuisine centrale on
fabrique directement et on sait il a le
choix il l'a toujours un féculent il a
toujours un légume
il a des crudités il a des fruits hilare
d'héritage du fromage il a le choix
souvent déjà d'une viande ou d'un
poisson
le crous est attentif à l'équilibré
entre étudiants et l'offre
traditionnelle permet pour 3 euros 25 à
chaque étudiant de bénéficier d'un repas
équilibré complet chaque fois en tant
qu'établissement public le crous doit
respecter le principe des marchés
publics et s'approvisionner donc auprès
de fournisseurs homologué à l'issue
d'une procédure de mise en concurrence
les achats par contre sont basées sur
des marchés publics qui sont soit
locaux c'est-à-dire pour l'académie de
versailles soit nationaux pour
l'ensemble des vous nos critères sont
basées majoritairement sur la qualité un
de nos marchés en régionale et le marché
des fruits et légumes et que à partir de
la semaine prochaine on lance une une
quinze jours sur le local et de manière
plus ponctuelle ce crous s'approvisionne
auprès de circuits courts
par exemple pour la semaine du goût
on va avoir le thème cette année c'est
le local donc on va faire intervenir des
producteurs franciliens
une recette qui semble faire l'unanimité
chez les étudiants de ce resto u de
saint quentin en yvelines
il ya plusieurs choix entré chez les
poissons le dessert il y avait des
foules et des pâtisseries des yaourts
des fruits
j'avais un peu peur de la cantine ce
bout parce que alors j'avais j'avais
essayé tout aimé parlement soutenant les
restos revenir ce cachet déjà passé par
là c'est super mais gaby et du combat
revanche hong haeran le choix un choix
alimentaires essentiels pour cette
population qui se nourrit mal un
étudiant sur cinq saute au moins un
repas dans la journée et 14% d'entre eux
ne mangent ni fruits ni légumes